you guys have you add up all the time
you're doing mail order comedy and then
all the time that you've been doing this
show you've been working together for a
long time and you always hear about I
mean it's not just rock bands but also
sketch troops famous sketch troops they
start fighting after a while because
it's it's too much well too much
together time for too long have you guys
had that absolutely you know it's a it's
a relationship in relationships take
work and you know you you guys have been
together for a while now you make it
work you know we don't work our magic is
that we are surrounded by it we don't
speak to each other off-camera
we're we're surrounded by lawyers and
we're constantly suing each other and
then we just fake it on television which
is a great call but like in the
beginning stages of me and the dudes we
pretty much have always spent life on
top of each other in all ways but yeah
so like before we had the show we kind
of our big break that wasn't a break at
all we went on like a comedy tour where
the National Lampoon resurrected the
lemmings which was like this really
famous stage show from the 70s
super-sweet group with like John Belushi
and Chevy Chase and all that but we were
the new class so definitely a downgrade
but yeah we went on tour and it was it
was it was quite a mess and I think
that's where Adam and I actually got in
probably our biggest fight well you guys
got into a fight yeah yeah it almost
came to blows mm-hmm I would say it was
basically over the fact that we were
sharing this hotel room and Adam had
called the nice bed and you know when we
came back from our night of partying and
night on the town the big success I was
pretty drunk and you know pants were
down for some reason but I ended up
passing out on the bed he claimed which
you can't do no and well his wrist I
passed out like with my butt in the bear
butt in the air so that that that uh
that pissed Adam off for some reason I
don't know why but um we were in some
town outside of Chicago he grabbed a
piece of deep-dish pizza and he just
spiked it into my butt crack
there was sauce everywhere and I'm like
what are you doing like we're getting
paid about $100 for every show we're
doing combined I'm like you just ruined
the entire the bedsheets the walls this
is coming and like we're gonna go broke
we're gonna have to that slice of pizza
is pretty much seen edible at this point
oh you know after being smacked in the
butt crack I got up in Adams face I'm
like what's up bro dude we got beef do
we need to have words you didn't say do
we got beef it was something very close
to that okay but look at this whole time
there's food hanging out of you oh I
didn't pull my pants up either but we're
nose to nose and I'm like so what's the
problem here
he's like dude no more butts
I like no more butts what no more butts
okay fine no more buts no more putts in
our videos
no more putts at all well you sent to
settle the like adults
you